ich habe mich sehr gewundert als ich das
papier der drei parteien nach den
sondierungen gelesen habe ich war sehr
positiv überrascht ich bin jetzt davon
überzeugt wir werden eine ampel
regierung bekommen daran gibt es für
mich keinen zweifel mehr das ist keine
not regierung die da entsteht das ist
auch kein windschief zusammengezimmerte
kompromiss gebäude die haben sehr
intelligent verhandelt die haben nämlich
einst begriffen bei den drei parteien
muss jeder seine big points kriegen
seine sucht existenziellen erfolge und
wenn er die kriegt ist das alles
miteinander zu vereinbaren also nicht
die berühmten schnittflächen darüber
wieder diskutiert wird und dann die die
punkte der anderen zu verbessern durch
ständiges weiter verhandeln also jetzt
morgens konkret zu machen die fdp
versucht die zwölf euro mindestlohn auf
11 eur 25 runter zu verhandeln und
wiederum
geht die spd versucht dann bestimmte
positionen der der grünen aufzuweichen
wenn man so vorgeht hat man am ende nur
ein wischiwaschi programm und alle
ärgern sich in diesem punkt diesem fall
stehen die aber nebeneinander die haben
einander gefügt was ihnen wichtig ist
dass die fdp keine steuererhöhungen
keine vermögenssteuer die die grünen
kohleausstieg nichts wo 38 schon dann
sondern 230
eine ein solardach pflicht und ähnliches
ist für die ganz wichtig die spd
wiederum mindestlohn keine erhöhung des
rentenalters und und verschiedene anders
sein und man liest dass durch und denkt
sich das passt gar nicht schlecht
zueinander das ist kein stückwerk das
ergänzt sich und ich bin immer sehr
kritisch gegenüber solchen parole
ausgegeben werden das ist ein
fortschritt regierung aber das ist
gemessen an dem was wir hatten ist es
eine weil alles was da vereinbart worden
ist zeigt nach vorne ich bin sehr
gespannt darauf was sie davon umsetzen
können und man kann sich auch schon
ausmalen wenn wir welche ministerien
krieg ich nehme mal an dass die fdp das
finanzministerium und das
digitalisierungs ministerium kriegt und
die grünen kriegen das außenministerium
auswärtige amt und natürlich das thema
ministerium die spd kriegt natürlich
arbeit und soziales und vermutlich
verteidigung müsste auch schon wer
nämlich den gerne jetzt den
generalsekretär der soldaten familie
kommt und der verteidigungsausschuss
gesessen hat es ist der erste verteilung
wäre der erst verdanken uns seit
jahrzehnten der was von der sache
versteht das kann man der bundeswehr nur
wünschen also gute sache und eine ganz
besonderes guten erfolg hat christian
linder erreicht ihr parteichef der hat
nämlich jetzt so mal das trauma der
gescheiterten
jamaika sondierungen abgestreift dass er
in der regierung verhindert die anderen
haben genau erkannt die anderen beiden
dass der einen erfolg braucht um damit
zu machen er kann sich ins bei seiner
klientel überall sehen lassen dass eine
linke regierung eingestiegen ist denn er
hat ja steuererhöhungen verhindert und
eine vermögenssteuer wir müssen nichts
vorzuwerfen er hat auch eine zusätzliche
koalitionsoptionen gewonnen dadurch der
man kann wirklich fröhlich sein und wenn
wir heute abend uns angucken
erstens ist das die neue regierung davon
bin ich überzeugt zweitens wissen wir
jetzt die cdu csu sitzt auf der
oppositionsbank auch das hat sich heute
entschieden ich stimme zu total dass du
sagst dass das dass die ampel kommen
wird ich glaube auch dass last king war
ein guter verteidigungsminister wäre
absolut ich glaube aber dass es ein
bisschen voreilig ist zu sagen dass das
irgendwie eine gute regierung und der
gute start guter start wäre das papier
ist gut ja das stimmt nur ich glaube
dass ein böses aufwachen geben könnte
weil im hinblick auf die
linken-bundestagsabgeordnete die es dort
gibt die humoristin ist es zur rolle
spielen werden die grüne jugend in eine
große rolle spielen werden und ich
glaube das wird noch wahnsinnig krachen
und ich glaube das hat man natürlich
jetzt nicht gemerkt weil da sind alle
real los bei der spd bei den grünen
sowieso bei der fdp die jetzt verhandelt
haben aber wenn das sozusagen reingeht
in den bundestag und dann sozusagen die
maßnahmen besprochen werden dann mit
kevin kühnert schon sehen wie ihr
sozusagen seine soldaten um sich nicht
bestimmen da völlig zurück nicht nur die
nicht nur der frontmann auch sind 50
jusos in der bundestagsfraktion und die
beiden parteivorsitzenden hat mir heute
schon gesehen mit welchem gesicht und
die daneben stand kirchen keine
vermögenssteuer und keine
steuererhöhungen das ist natürlich
bitter
die aber hatte die nicht das gefühl da
stehen drei kanzler ich meine annalena
baerbock integriert jetzt mal das ist
eine sehr risikobereit war das doch
eigentlich und irgendwo hatten bei einem
respekt vor den kommenden kanzler oder
falls die beiden robert habeck und
christian sind naja dieses
modernisierungs quasi die mobilisierung
stempel auf der stirn man die trends bei
twitter ging ja auch fdp und grüne die
spd war zwar mit genannt aber fehlte da
irgendwie und das war so vom gefühl her
eigentlich war es höchst erstaunlich
weil die fdp und die grünen die sich
fundamental entgegenstanden absolut
diesen koalitions vorbereitenden
gesprächen auf einmal durch dieses
instagram zählt zu den besten freunden
und inhalte nicht haben sie es geschafft
sich als modernisierer und das ist
vielleicht dass ich überhaupt so
fundamental zum beispiel 2017 denkt man
ja immer es werden den grünen oder das
fdp grünen ich keine damals ist ja eine
union gescheitert 2017 bei jamaika nicht
an den grünen als geben wollt und riss
ihr gesagt
ich glaube in manchen punkten sind die
beiden mit zielen der weg ist natürlich
komplett konträr ich finde vor allem
bemerkenswert und da werde ich noch mal
sagen mit ich glaube eher dass jamaika
auch ein punkt war für christian lendner
weil ich würde schon sagen christian
lindner ist schon unbeugsam er ist
widerspenstig und ich glaube auch nicht
dass die anwesenden dachte okay er macht
jetzt alles mit meiner wohnung bild wenn
man rückblickend guckt auf die jamaika
sondierung kann man heute anhand dieser
sondierung erkennen was angela merkel
alles falsch gemacht hat die haben
nämlich über 200 punkte gleichzeitig
verhandelt die haben wichtig nicht von
unwichtig entschieden und die wichtigen
sachen müssen die parteichefs auge in
auge miteinander vereinbaren und dann
müssen die vereinbaren die big points
werden kommen durch jeder kriegt sein
spezial anliegen in einer sonst
funktioniert es nicht und das hat die
merkel damals nicht gemacht sie hat sich
nur um die grünen gekümmert und an
christian lindner stehe habe ich immer
verstanden ich wäre auch hausgeräte
ticket.de es bei paul wird noch kommen
denn hier ist noch nicht geklärt wie
hoch diese co2 bepreisung wird und ist
es klar dass aus diesem topf quasi alles
finanziert werden soll was normal nicht
finanziert werden kann also vielleicht
kommt da noch für den bürger die
bürgerin ein aufwachen mit kosten das
wird natürlich spannend sei nicht jeder
regierung kommt noch was die welt dreht
sich weiter da kommt noch 1000 problem
[Gelächter]
jetzt haben sie es gar nicht wahr es
wäre nicht schlecht wenn er das heute
auch sagen könnte von berlin ja ja ja
ich kann es leider ist der link wenn man
ein bisschen mehr aus den sitzungen
erzählen langweilig geworden
sein handy alarm
[Gelächter]
wir haben also ist doch klar ich sie
haben grade mal reflektiert 20 17 haben
eine ganz andere situation gehabt ich
meine da hat man nicht mit robert habeck
sondern mit ihrem trittin verhandelt da
haben wir situationen gehabt dass cdu
und csu tief zerstritten waren da waren
wir parteien am tisch und nicht 3 und
jetzt haben wir zwei köpfe mit christian
lindner und robert robert habeck die
gesagt haben wir wollen eine
fortschritts koalition machen und die
haben die idee dazu entwickeln um mit
dieser idee gemeinsam in der
verhandlungstaktik einzutreten und damit
auch die themen zu setzen dann halte ich
für unheimlich wichtig und das ist jetzt
das ergebnis und ich teile die
auffassung dass es sicherlich hier und
da noch mal ruckeln wird aber das ist
völlig normal dass man aber jetzt eine
grundlinie hat eine grundlinie die man
verhandelt hat hinter der man jetzt die
details verabredet das ist glaube ich
ein richtig großer schritt damit die
dinge auch von der haltung her gelingen
können und diese haltung die hat gefehlt
top job kann man die liberale
handschrift ich finde schon ich mein
kein tempolimit keine steuererhöhungen
also das waren ja schon die in sachen
bei warum wurde christian auch die fdp
endlich auf sie gelegt weil man nicht
weit in den linksruck
digitalisierung erkenne ich ihn auch
drin ja von schuldenbremse plant andreas
ein richtig toller erfolg für ihn alle
big points hat er durch gekriegt und die
anderen parteien übrigens auch das ist
nicht nur ihm so gegangen aber
tiefe innere befreiung das was heute
vorgelegt worden jetzt ist er wieder
frei geworden und ich freue mich ich
freue mich nicht auf scholz' ehrlich
gesagt dabei ist man auch nicht weiter
als hamburg noch an comex ermittlungen
kommt dass da könnte noch einiges kommen
aber auf die beiden lindner und harbeck
freue ich mich dass die haben wirklich
das finanzministerium ausfüllen kann und
das ist wirklich schafft da bin ich auch
mal gespannt sagt das ist doch etwas
ganz an das was er bislang gemacht hat
und tatsächlich irgendwie da das
finanzministerium zu führen das wird
nicht leicht werden und ich bin gespannt
ob robert habe wer mich schon über post
bewegen wir was dir nicht tue und
natürlich haben sie darüber geredet
aber ich weise sie aber ich würde mich
nicht wundern was wird aus mir ich würde
mich nicht wundern wenn roman habe ich
doch außenminister würde ja denn der
wird sich das nicht antun mit zu einem
wirklich schwierigen ministerium umwelt
oder klima oder sowas wo es wirklich um
ganz viele details und uns durchsetzen
geht da glaube ich können uns von
anderen vielleicht sogar einen alten
bekannten gefasst machen arbeiten
schließen lässt dass jürgen trittin noch
mal eine rolle haben
ich glaube ich dass man habe
außenminister wird auf keinen fall ich
glaube dass er sozusagen tatsächlich das
inhaltliche was er immer gesagt hat er
will etwas verändern reformen blablabla
glaube ich schon also weil weil dann hat
er sozusagen das amt vor irgendwie
beliebtheit bekommen kann wie hast du
vollkommen recht habe auf der anderen
seite hat er das sehr geprägt diese
debatten kultur im sinne von ich will
jetzt hier was verändern eures dem
neustart und deutschland das leben nicht
unfair paar das ist vielleicht du bist
so ist der welle auf
java kam eigentlich beide bei der wahl
abgewatscht die wollen beide kanzler
werden schlechtes ergebnis laschet ist
jetzt eigentlich weg und werbung wird
jetzt außenministerin ist es doch so
schön das leben sein kann die haben
beide versagt eigentliche wahlkampf
einen fehler gemacht der eine ist jetzt
der buhmann der nation und haben wieder
aus sagt katja prozent dazu gewonnen das
muss man immer noch sehen doch
wir brauchen nicht würden war kein
frieden der war natürlich dieser größe
insbesondere am anfang aber trotzdem hat
sich immer noch prozent dazu gewonnen
von daher ist es nicht vergleichbar und
armin laschet der tut mir tatsächlich
seiten muss ich sagen also wenn man sich
ausdenkt was da jetzt passiert der wüst
wird ministerpräsident der sitze jetzt
überhaupt nix außer dann irgendwie in
japan gelang tatsächlich das verrückte
ist ja bei armin laschet das heißt bis
zuletzt auch nicht geglaubt hat dass er
wirklich weg ist ja ja das gefühl
transportiert hat jamaika kommt noch
weil christian lindner
immer gesagt hat ja ja machen eine
jamaika und das wird schon und offenbar
gab es auch vorher eine aussage vor der
wahl das habe ich zumindest gehört dass
bei einem gewissen abstand zur spd bis
zu vier prozent hieß es glaube ich oder
bis zu drei prozent abstand denn wenn
man zweiter würde ist immer noch jamaika
ausging hat also bald wieder
davon ausgehen können dass dieser
fortschritts gedanke den fdp und grüne
gemeinsam entwickelt haben mit der
sozialdemokratie nicht trägt also ich
habs grad ihren berlin erlebte reden ja
später noch drüber das muss nicht immer
gleich ein automatismus bei der
sozialdemokratie es gibt auch und dafür
kann es ja noch die reste frauen umgeben
ja aber paul ein wichtiger punkt ist ja
auch bei arminia steht ja muss ja auch
irgendwo die realitäten anrichten und du
sprichst viel mit cdu ministern und
ministerpräsidenten mit
csu-ministerpräsident du weißt doch wie
so oft gesprochen haben sie haben gesagt
wenn der uns in die zweite position
führt dann ist der weg das haben sie ja
intern schon gesagt weil sie so so
verdrießlich waren mit der einen
vorsprung der sie sicher ins kanzleramt
hätte segeln sollen da eben zunichte
gemacht
[Musik]